I heard you've been playing guitar in
quarantine like you've decided to teach
yourself guitar is that correct that is
true yeah how's that going
I think I'm doing great and my wife and
daughter are like what are you playing
what song is that like come on you can't
tell and they can't tell what songs are
you working on would you like me to tell
you would you like to try and figure out
what I'm sorry let's play named that -
all right let me hear a song
[Music]
any idea John hi none plug ladies and
gentlemen I think Robin has it come on
Robin its is it walk alone No
welcome to the new age in the day I'm
here I thought it was you have the lyric
Robin not this one okay but that's not
the title I'll give you a hint they play
live on the show many times including uh
very recently Green Day oh I walk these
streets then the Boulevard of broken
dreams that's it John you're I'm telling
you man I think you're a prodigy in fact
that Robin got that is amazing I got one
more
[Music]
give me a head a hair long beautiful
hand don't think that that's the
beginning of my sweet lord
really it is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I can sort of hear it now
at the prophesy fake after the stick or
what chords are such a minor in a oh
great
how about this one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
at ARMA what is that say giving Hotel
California let's start the world
shittiest band
a Fleetwood Big Mac
that you playing my sweet lord
I was with you Howard oh we were jamming
yeah
[Music]
alright enough of jamming people
you